Maybe later you're
going to be at a protest,
and someone's going to
have a poster that says,
"They buried us, but they
didn't know wewere seeds."
That's poetry.
You might be in your
U.S. History class,
and your teacher
mayplay a video of
Martin Luther King Jr.
saying: "We will be able to
hew out of this mountain
of despair a stone of hope."
That's poetry.
Or maybe even here,
in New York City,
you're going to go visit
the Statue of Liberty
where there's a sonnet that
declares,as Americans,
"Give us your tired,
your poor,
your huddled masses
yearning to be free."
So you see, when
someone asks me
to write a poem
that's not political,
what they'rereally
asking me is to
not ask charged and
challenging questions
in my poetic work,
andthat does not work,
because poetry is
always at the pulse
of the most dangerous
and the most daring
questions that a nation
or a world might face.